thank you um so this is Joint work with
mat doel from
um uh cck technical Czech University in
Prague and Jules hedes from
Oxford um so before people wanted to go
on Mars they really wanted to understand
compositionality in natural language and
so basically this work goes all the all
the way back to the work of Aristo
and then later on in the Middle Ages
okam and austino and all the people who
worked on Modo logic Were Somehow
inspired by analyzing the linguistic
Theory and later on of course we have
the work of uh F and Russell and
wienstein but the models I will consider
are uh more formal and more
recent so
um I'll very briefly look at these five
models of natural life language um so
the foremost uh categorial type Logics
or categorial type grammars of auk uh
and later on bar so these people really
used an algebraic approach to analyze
the syntax of natural language lambc uh
in 58 really formalized what they were
doing using the theory of residuated
monoids and at the same time uh
presented a sound and complete uh proof
system G and proof system for it and
then lots of other people have worked on
these settings later on more God more
real there students and colleagues and
similarly for Claudia casadio and
Anella um then of course also we have
the work of CHS generative grammar
probably most of you are familiar with
that and in the 70s Richard monu a
student of
tari um he worked on what people later
on called formal semantics for natural
language so as these two first models
are sort of um analyze the syntax of
natural
language montagu if you want provided a
denotational semantics for it and then I
so much want to say these two other
models are operational semantics but
they aren't because they don't look like
anything like operational semantics but
these are like very semantic see so Z
also in ble he invented fil logic but at
the same time he also has a few papers
on phic semantics for natural language
and then we have the vector space model
of natural language or distributional
semantics inspired by the work of zik
Harris who chk's supervisor and it's p
in Bley and John rer first whose quote
you might have come across who said You
shall know award but compan KS uh from
the context in which it often
occurs so there are some uh relations
between these models uh for example uh
right after auk Works gu sham his
students they showed how you can go from
generative grammars to educated grammars
later on pentus showed how you can go
from generative grammar to lamb grammar
this work was built on by bukovski who
showed how you can go from lamb Grammer
to something just called a pregroup
Grammer which we shall discuss
later and in the 80s these ventum showed
how you can go from this kind of
typological grammars to formal semantics
for your k type
arism but these two models F semantics
and distributional semantics aren't
related to these other models and my
goal today is to bring all of them
together my real goal is something else
which will become clear at the end of
the talk hopefully but that's how you
can see it as
well uh and the idea is I'm going to use
category
Theory um because so I have something
here to show you um because well U there
are categorical models of ariso
syllogisms by students of
uh so I thought we should all use
category to why
not and uh
so right okay so just to give you an
idea because I don't have time to
present each of these systems but just
to give you an idea so this is how u a
lamback proof system will
analyze a construct of natural language
such as the mathematician whom Kazmir
talks to so you basically have in this
case a natural
deduction proof
tree um for the case of generative
grammar you have the generation Tre of
your sentence CH is famous example
here um
then for the case of montagu you'll get
the par three of a Lambda calculus
St so
then f logictics is very different so
they consider words not phrases and
sentences some words do not have sharp
definitions for example
skyscaper can have various different
floors how would you know what is the
skycraper from the number of floors that
it has f I says do not worry let's look
at the number of frows that we have
observed and then you can do things with
this like take their minimum take their
maximum and take the average and that's
how you get to define the vague notion
of a skyscraper so you see very
different no trees here and distribution
semantics uh is still very different so
the goal of this people is to analyze
word in context so then you are given
documents large corpora of text here's
an example and what you do uh which was
inspired by ideas of haris and F and
firstone in Berkeley by Rubenstein and
good enough is that you turn your piece
of text into what they call a
cooccurrence matrix so you label The
Columns of your Matrix with something uh
with labels that you call context words
the rows are labeled with uh Target
words and then you count how many times
your Target word occurred with your
context word so occurred with means
adjustment to in the same sentence
having a grammatical relation with or
occurring in a window of for example
five words in either side so people play
the notion of contextuality here and
then it's kind of obvious once you have
this cooccurrence Matrix um how to turn
it into a vector
space and then at the the distance
between these
vectors are good indicators of how often
these words occur in the same context
which will give you a notion of semantic
similarity so from this uh currence
matric you can see that moth and
Butterfly are close to each other and
both of them far from Vampire because of
the cooccurrence or lack thereof with
blood the numbers are real by the
way and okay
so right so the idea is how do we relate
these models using um Notions of
compositionality and logic so that's
what I'm going to do
now um I'm going to use the theory of
compact Clause categories so here are
some very very brief uh definitions I
think Dan will introduce them more
precisely
later so a compact CL category is
basically your tensor category um where
tensor has a unit and every object has a
left and a right ad joint which means
we've got um two Epsilon morphism for
anation of object with its ad joint and
two etom morphism for creation of an
object with its ad
joint now a symmetric compa close
category admits a notion of a bialgebra
over its object a b algebra is a pair of
a Comm Comm Al monoid so we've got Co
associativity and Co
morphism and then associativity and unit
morphism and then we have four a which
basically tell you if you need to do
something and there are different ways
of doing them it doesn't really matter
in which order you do this so for
example um if I want to create two
copies of
something I can do
twice this morphism so Iota tensor
Iota or I can um first create one copy
one
aota and then make it into
two by using my me map so it doesn't
matter which you
use I think are deeper meanings to these
axom but I don't fully understand what
they are why understand what is by albas
is that they're really the
ancestors of uh a logical operators of
these days conjunction and
djunction uh okay so different by
algebras for conjunction and disjunction
Etc so examples of compal categories I
think the most trivial example is the
category of sets and
relations um it's symmetric so Epsilon
and Delta collapse to one morphism for
each and of two for here's your Epsilon
map and here's your ET
map uh really acting a very simple way a
more interesting example is category of
sets and many valued
relations um so here you fix a
quantal and then you define a many
valued relation R from A to B to be a
function that assigns values from this
quantal to pairs from A and B position
is defined in this very nice way if I
want to compose R an
S um so obviously I compos in the normal
relational way I get pairs a c but what
is the value assigned to them so I look
at the value or assigns to a and
multiply by the value s assigns to BC
and then some of all such
pairs we have shown but I think it has
been shown before as well that the
category of set many Valu relations
is compact close and also self ad joint
in the same way as well so tensor is
Cartesian product single set is its unit
and Epsilon and atom Ms are defined as
follows so Epsilon relates A and B to
star with which value if a is equal to B
you assign the unit of the quantal the
unit of the monoid and if a is not equal
to B you assign the bottom of your lce
to it similarly for the atom
map okay um one of my favorite examples
is what Lambic invented in 1999 which is
called the pregroup
algebra um these are partially or that
monoid where every element has a left
and a right ad joint uh which means we
have these four inequalities and you can
immediately see why this is a partial
order compact close
category uh um
so something else which is a com back CL
category and is also very interesting is
an arithmetic example also given by
lambc as a model of a pregroup that is
the set of all unbounded monotone
functions over integers but you can
Define the left to the right adint of
your function using uh the minimum and
maximum over
integers uh
okay so
how do these different models relate to
each other using combat close categories
and
albas so the big picture is like so um I
start with a Contex free grammar chopski
Style translated uh and I use bushkov
translation to a residuated monoid lamb
grammar and then take it to a pregroup
grammar and then here here is where my
syntax lives basically
and then I will interpret the syntax in
a compact Clause category which as by
algebra over objects functorially using
a strongly monal functor so I'm
providing semantics for the syntax this
is algebra of forms using monag
terminology and here I've got the
algebra of
meaning now if I instantiate my combat
close category into sets and relation
that's where my formal semantics
leaves um if I embed set and relations
into vectors qu vectors and linear Maps
that's where my distribution of
semantics
lives now if I fix the bases for my
vectors then my Vector calculus becomes
like a matrix
calculus and category of U relations can
also be embedded in category of many
valed relations where the philic
semantic leaves and then there is an
isomorphism between many VAR relations
and matrices so everything becomes
together here if you want do you guys
agree what do you mean by embedding e
into
F uh I have some I'll show you later so
a set goes to vectors where span by the
elements of the set but it's not a
funter no no it is are not funter that's
why I put this funny symbols
I didn't put Arrow so what do you guys
think is everybody with me so far okay
okay sure okay so a bit more
formally uh so here's my context for
grammar terminals non terminals a
designated end point s for sentence a
set of rules this I'll take into a
pregroup grammar so these are the
terminals and these are two designated
objects the s is the image of that s and
this beta you take from certain types of
uh terminals I have an example for this
later if you want I can show you this is
my strong leidal functor so you have uh
it takes you to compact those category C
with two designated objects W and s w
for beta S for S to W and S we add three
what are called logical by algebras each
so we have six by algebras in total can
you guess why three
each um so it's for intersection Union
and
subtraction so okay where is
compositionality so compositionality
shows up in two different places um one
is obviously why this functorial passage
it's strongly
monoidal uh the Dage of the funori
tensor is a tensor of the images of the
functor so that's one way
compositionality comes in but also
linguists work with something which they
call the principle of lexical
substitution which in this setting gets
the following
form uh when you want to calculate the
meaning of a string of words W1 to WN
you look at the syntactic structure in
our case given to us here so we bring
over the syntactic structure from
Context three grammar it becomes
uh an inequality in your pregroup
grammar and then a morphism of the
category here so that is this overline
bracket
Alpha and then you compose that so
that's one one so that's by composition
composite with the Testo product that's
also another composition of the
categorical meanings of the words within
this
string um I don't know why why do they
call this the principle of lexical
substitution and not like the principle
of
compositionality
really
so what do I have next so let's look
at um an example so we start with a
context free grammar which covers a
reasonable fragment of natural language
we can actually do more but uh we can do
relative pronouns uh questions and many
more things but I don't have time to
show so here is like a sentence uh which
is created by a noun phrase followed by
a verb phrase a verb phrase is created
by a verb followed by a noun phrase
here's where the quantifiers come in a
noun phrase is a
determiner applied to a noun where your
determiner is basically all your natural
language quantifiers some almost many at
most at
least and then you can form more
sentences and also the similarly for
nouns noun phrases verbs and verb
phrases but I don't have corresponding
Rules by putting and and or between your
sentences or by negating your
sentence um you have uh so this nend
here uh can be things like men cats dogs
VPS are created by this rule or they can
be intransitive verbs sleep and
snore the V there they are transitive
like love eat and
hate um the formal
semantics for this
CFT um is a universal set of reference
together with a map from the language of
the CFG to subsets of various different
products of U here are some examples if
you are a
noun and similarly an intransitive VP
you become a subset of U
obviously if you are
um a transitive V you become a subset of
U times
U why why are both nouns and verb
phrases become subsets of the same
universe I can imagine a universe of all
nouns like all you men cats other nouns
but but you saying that the sleep should
also be in there yeah so thetic sleep is
the set of all things that
sleep for example say cut one sleeps cut
two sleeps person one sleeps person two
sleeps so and then for cuts you also
that have subsets of the
universe is that a standard trick in
linguistics you're turning an
intransitive verb into a a
predicate like unary relation for both
nouns and in transitive relations for
everything that was like a very good
idea of mon to use higher
order of things for everything sorry I'm
not
[Laughter]
nervous I I don't know why I'm
nervous okay H this is very interesting
and so that gives
you uh semantics for quantifiers so
quantifier so in natural language
determiners are quantifiers
is a map from Power set of U to power
set of power set of U so you take a
subset of U A and D of a is a set of all
subsets of U that have a certain
relationship with that thing maybe I
should give an example so for
example d
a for D being
sum the set of all subsets X of U
where a intersection X is non
empty yeah and so on and so forth for
all the quantifiers the cardinalities of
these sets become very important
here okay so what about our phrases so
this all then goes in very nicely
compositionally you actually really have
to do anything so the meaning of an MP
generated by this rule is the meaning of
the phrase that's n which is the meaning
of your determiner applied to the
meaning of your
noun why were determiners going from the
power set of you to the power set of the
power set of you a set of
sets uh so sum applied to a is a set of
all subsets of U whose intersection with
a is non
empty
something most takes the set of people
to the set of those sets that contain
most people so there are many
possibilities for being most people and
you want all of those sets to
be you see for most a the set subset of
a it's going from you to the power set
of you but you're like you can slap
another no it's not taking credit
most is true apply to that
predictive
okay extra power
setus as well yeah it's a very nice way
of
doing um so then for sentences so here
you assign sets everywhere like sets for
terminals sets for phrases when it comes
to the sentence you def find the truth
value so the meaning of a sentence is
obviously the meaning of MP followed by
VP is VP applied to MP and then you look
at this and if it is not empty you say
my sentence is true so the meaning of
sentence becomes its truth
value and then obviously then you do
your normal uh truth
table operations to get undone or un not
here so now the question is how can we
do all of this in a compact close
category you only have a tensor and this
Epsilon and ETO maps how can we do this
logical operations
um and the answer is of course via by
algebras so we have three by algebras
for w and s six by alas in total how do
they work so
um here we're working in category real
to do formal semantics so we fix an
object W power set of U in the category
remember W was designated object and I
Define the following by algebra
um the common map copies so uh Delta
relates A to B and C if a b and c on are
the same and it uh sends a to
Star all the
time uh the intersection by
algebra takes an element uh Takes A and
B from s * s relates it to C as
so these are subsets of s if C is equal
to a intersection B and then it's unit
says the star to a subset of s
if H if that subset of set x a is the
unit of
intersection uh so that's your Universe
here five minutes really okay okay so
you play the same trick and Define Union
and subtraction as well
everything goes over to many Valu
relations very easily the values that
you assigned are basically either the
unit of the quantal or the bottom of the
latis if the condition is true and if
it's false otherwise so a subtraction
associative subtraction
associative don't you need associativity
for
bi can we talk later
okay okay huh so now we have are some
results here so
um we've gone from this model to this
model uh what happened to the notion of
Truth um so here we Define true truth as
follows a sentence s is true if it
relates a star to star and then we prove
that if a sentence is true
here then there is if and only if it's
true
here this kind of soundness and
completeness with of the compact close
categorical semantics with regard to the
formal
semantics everything carries over to
Vector space set um so you use the
embedding of a set going to a vector
space span by the set a relation go goes
obviously to a linear map on the
corresponding embedded Vector spaces and
you define the notion of Truth in this
case be when this gu is a linear map now
you apply to Star if you get uh anything
but the
origin which is this is like the unit of
the tensor in this case then you say my
sentence was true and then again we can
prove soundness and completeness with
regard to the relational
model okay and similarly the notion of
Truth carries over to many Valu
relation uh okay I'll skip the
example so then you can say so what um
what we're doing now is like we've
manage to do true theoretic semantics
using by algebras and compact close
categories and somebody can ask us like
why are you doing this we know already
how to do choth value semantics in
relations why do you want to restrict
yourself only to compact close
categories and then have to add by
algebras to the objects to do logic
similarly for phic Vector spes the
answer is uh the real goal of this talk
is to add logic and composition to the
vectors um and that's what we have done
in in way of doing it we have created a
a gigantic object Vector space or a
power set of view so the question is
does this make sense to start with what
is Vector space over a set of set that's
the cooccurrence mat I showed you at the
beginning wasn't this type at all so
there are two answers to this question
one is uh there is a school of linguist
who really want to
build uh the U your set of reference
inter notation of semantics from a
corpus so the idea is that assume there
was a camera in all parts of the
Universe from the beginning this cam
recorded all individuals and everything
that they did and you transcribe the
film that is your Corpus and then you
sit down and separate who are the
individuals and who did what so these
are some people who are working in this
uh line the other way is that I was
actually lying to you a little bit when
I showed the cence Matrix in fact uh the
bases of the of your vector space are
very rarely just single words they are
poers uh they are like sets of subsets
of your vocabulary so it's not you but
the sigma is a vocabulary of your
language so in this case what does a
subset of the vocabulary mean so they
can be either lemas so a LMA kill is a
canonical form of all these
words so that's your subset or if you
started the highly dimensional Vector
space you might do dimensionality
deduction in which case your bases end
up to be sets of something called Fe
features so in reality usually you're
working here
really um so these do make sense but
they're of course
huge and then the trick I've been using
is to instead of working in Vector
spaces and here we import the
data um from the
vectors into the fuzzy semantics and
then end up working here just much
so I think everybody maybe sees how this
works so you have to uh when you have
formal semantics you have subsets of the
universe when you go to fuzzy semantics
you have to uh fify them by assigning
numbers to them so how do you think of
this so these numbers here you think of
as the degree to which in this case
something is a cut and this degrees we
can now read from distributional data it
doesn't really make sense to say
something is
0.3
cut maybe it's a cut UMO or this cut
here maybe lost one
leg it doesn't really make sense but
these do make sense so you can say R is
the degree to which something has the
same context as cat shares the same
company as cat it's contextually similar
to cat and these oh some is noing thank
you so this you can read from your
quence
Matrix uh okay so that was the idea we
have been experimenting uh with this
model uh so you have logic and
quantifier what you do is inment there
is a notion of entailment for words in
distribution of cic have extended it two
sentences so next plan is to do it for
Quantified
sentences and
finally conclusion that is that there is
a compositional vector model of natural
language using compat CLA categories
work of many different people some of
them listed here it doesn't have
quantifiers and there's no logic there
so we solve this problem
here and on the way of doing that we
provided a c compact CL category called
functorial f semantics for natural
language have something to say but
thanks for inviting
me and maybe it's nice to end with this
quote from
Russell Point making time for a
question you want to ask
oh